[Music]
this year's New York International Auto
Show begins its final weekend here in
the city today and it ends the big Auto
Show season across the nation scores of
innovative models are on display but car
lovers have yet to see one particular
variety of vehicle here or anywhere else
a production automobile with a top speed
of over 300 miles per hour Don Dahler is
here with the intense race to make it
happen Don I hope you have your seat
belt good morning good morning to give
you a little perspective 300 miles per
hour is approaching half the speed of
sound it may be hard to imagine what
that would feel like behind the wheel of
a car there are three companies on the
road to finding that out we visited one
headquartered in Texas
[Music]
this is what Hennessey performance
engineering is known for obscene speed
turning hot cars into supercars and The
Exorcist is one of their most popular a
modified Camaro that goes from zero to
60 in less than three seconds its top
speed
217 miles per hour but that's not the
texas-based company's fastest model five
years ago founder and CEO John Hennessy
set a new record for speed in a
production vehicle with his 270 mile an
hour venom gt
[Applause]
tantalizingly close to the magic number
why is 300 the Holy Grail well I think
you know at some point in time maybe a
hundred years ago there was the first
car that could hit a hundred miles an
hour and fast forward into the late 90s
and what was the first production car
that you could go by that you know could
break two miles north and so I think
we're now kind of on the cusp I know
we've got a car that's got that
capability you know some of the
challenges we were talking about earlier
that car is the venom f5 I'm fascinated
by the fact that you've designed this
from the ground up we wanted the car the
the best performing car that we could
build very very driver focused kind like
a race car but focused in terms of it
has one purpose and that is to go fast
it has a seven point six liter
twin-turbo v8 engine cranking out more
than 1600 horsepower designers were told
form had to follow function the car had
to weigh less than 3,000 pounds but look
amazing I wanted to have distinctive
headlights I kind of feel like the
headlights on a car kind of like the
eyes of a person and so so just come up
with some cool headlights and they came
up with a comet F shaped for a five
headlight but there are other entrants
in this race to 300 fame super car
makers Koenig seg and Bugatti are also
vying to be the first you're up against
some big names sir and they have big
resources behind them you don't you're a
single company here you're putting all
this financing up yourself do you stand
a chance oh I think so I love being the
underdog I'd much rather be the underdog
than the one favor I don't think that
we're gonna see a car break 400 miles
down or break 500 miles an hour so I
kind of feel like a 300 mile an hour
production Series Road car it's kind of
the automotive Mount Everest I started
racing when I was 12
Travis a coal ski is editor-in-chief of
Road & Track magazine how much of a
disadvantage in this race do you think
that Texas company is Tennessee's
company has been known for tuning cars
for a very very long time
they just recently built their own car
the venom so building their own car from
the ground up the first time ever
and claiming that it's gonna hit 300 an
hour is a really really big challenge
and what is it that is so challenging
about hitting that number where do I
start
I mean first off tire technology right
when you go above levels of 250 260
miles an hour you're stressing the
rubber and the tire and all the
compounds and everything so if something
were to come apart and fail at that
speed it would be catastrophic
right these cars generate an enormous
amount of heat so at those speeds heat
management is huge if it gets too hot it
can explode and the final thing that I
think is holding back is aerodynamics
when you're driving into the air the air
will act as a wall as it gets faster and
faster so it's either pushing the car
under the ground or it's possibly
generating lift and if you keep going
faster the car's gonna fly away so you
need the mixture of great aerodynamic
packaging heat packaging and 1,500 to
1,800 horsepower in order to make this
sort of thing happen but no listener
Location Location Location it takes a
lot of straight road to hit 300 miles
per hour Hennessey had access to a
runway at Florida's Kennedy Space Center
to reach 270 in the venom gt but he'll
need more than that to reach this goal
to run 300 miles an hour we're going to
need to have a public highway that we
can work with the state whether it's
Texas or Nevada where we can close the
highway to run but I think with five or
six miles that's what we need to run 300
and have plenty of room to to slow down
if you look at a map there's very few
places that have that length of it we're
talking three four five mile straights
in order to get up to this sort of speed
the problem is when you're on a road the
road has a gradient right and it's
sloped downward and then it's bumpy so
there's it's very unpredictable to do it
on a road so achieving that top speed is
going to be very very very difficult for
wherever they can do it building a car
from the ground up that can go that fast
is one thing you'd think finding people
to plop down 1.6 million plus to buy one
is another but think again Hennessey
says his first production run of 11
venom F fives are already spoken for
it's not something that you're going to
take down to the grocery store it's
almost like having a work of art hanging
in your house that you can just kind of
point to when people come over
kind of but you also have a hell of a
speeding ticket to hang with it
it's bespoke craftsmanship what you're
paying for is something that is
hand-built that no one else has and you
know you're paying for the bragging
rights you're paying to have something
that is incredible not just by the
standard of automotive but by the
standard of all engineering but for John
Hennessy whose love of fast cars started
when he was a child
the venom f5 means more than bragging
rights it means his family name could be
considered among the automotive greats
we talked to our kids that the f5 is our
legacy vehicle it's the vehicle that 50
years from now when I'm gone
that's the vehicle that people would be
kind of the pinnacle of the vehicles
that we've built
he has landed some funding from the oil
company Pennzoil they believe in him and
he expects to make an attempt to reach
300 miles per hour later this summer I
hope he makes it and I would drive that
to the gross proudly a quick trip
there's just one right now
that there that they're creating there
they're actually building them in Europe
in part and the design was there but
they're also putting it together here
and in Texas and we get to follow all of
this yes we are gonna revisit this when
he makes the run behind the wheel I
would do it anyway